المواجهه لن تكون ثنائيه بين واشنطن وبكين
في منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وانما
متعدده الاقطاب هذا هو الحال الذي فرضته
اتفاقيه شراء استراليا لغواصات هجوميه
تعمل بالطاقه النوويه بموافقه امريكيه
بريطانيه تحت ما يعرف باتفاقيه اوكوس ما
يضع الصين امام اكثر من خصم وقوه فالصفقه
التي ستبلغ تكلفتها نحو 245 مليار دولار
وستنفذ على مدار العقود الثلاثه المقبله
هدفها القريب هو بناء قوه بحريه ثابته
لمواجهه توسع النفوذ بكين في المنطقه اما
الهدف الابعد فهو جعل واشنطن قادره على
الاستفاده من حلفائها في مواجهه الصين دون
ان تكون وحيده امام قوه بكين البحريه
وزير دفاع استراليا
اكد ان الصفقه الغواصات النوويه كانت
ضروريه لامن بلاده في وقت تشهد منطقه
المحيط الهادئ اكبر حشد عسكري تقليدي في
المنطقه منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
نشاهد النظام العالمي القائمه على القواعد
يتعرض لضغط هائل في اوروبا الشرقيه وفي
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ ونحن نشهد اكبر
حشد عسكري تقليدي شهدناه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وهذا يحدث داخل منطقتنا
وعلينا الرد على ذلك
اما الصين وبلهجه شديده ادانت ما اعتبرته
الطريق الخاطئه والخطر الذي تسلكه الشراكه
المبرمه بين الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
واستراليا ضمن برنامج الغواصات
الصين تشدد على ان اتفاق اكسر بين امريكا
واستراليا وبريطانيا سيقود نظام عدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه ونعبر عن اعتراضنا
شديد عليه لانه يبين ان هذه الدول الثلاث
تغاضت عن القلق الذي عبرنا عنه واختارت
الطريقه الخطا
موقف روسيا لا يقل حده عن حليفتها
الاستراتيجيه اذ اتهمت اطراف الاتفاقيه
بتدبير مواجهه تستمر لسنوات في اسيا
العالم الانجلوساكسوني يبني تكتلات مثل
اوكوس ويطور البنى التحتيه لحلف شمال
الاطلسي في اسيا و يراهن بجديه على مواجهه
تستمر لسنوات طويله الولايات المتحده تبذل
مساعي لاخضاع دول اسيا لارادتها هذا يجب
ان يتوقف
اتفاق ثلاثي تقابله معارضه من روسيا
والصين وسيجبر الاخيره على التفكير اكثر
من مره قبل الاقدام على اي مواجهه تدور
حول تايوان او غيرها لان الخصم لم يعد
واحدا وانما ثلاثه ولكل منهم قوته الضاربه